some breaking news to bring you and the
bbc has today published a review that
was set up to establish the facts
around the decision to appoint martin
bashir as religious affairs
correspondent in september 2016 a role
that
was promoted to religion editor in 2018.
now this
review looked at three questions was the
recruitment process intended to find the
right person for the role
as opposed to being predetermined what
did those who appointed martin beshear
know about his previous misconduct in
relation to the 1995 panorama interview
and his other public controversies and
in what circumstances was
martin beshear's role regraded in 2018.
let's bring in our royal correspondent
rhianna mills who's been having a look
at that
review and rhiannon what has it
concluded
so i think it's worth reminding everyone
that this has actually come
as a result of that dyson report that
was released
at the end of may which was looking at
exactly how martin beshear had managed
to
uh secure that really explosive
interview with princess diana that
panorama interview back
uh in 1995 and through that dyson report
they found that martin beshear had
in essence lied he'd used fake bank
statements
in order to convince earl spencer so
princess diana's brother
to introduce him to diana and made them
both feel that they were being spied on
in some sense so in essence he used that
to secure the interview
it was then within the bbc found out
that he had used fake documents
and that was then covered up now as a
result of that
report there were also then questions
about why exactly
after martin beshear had left the bbc
wyatt was decided to re-hire him in 2016
under the role of religious affairs
correspondent
now this latest review in essence has
found that when it came to the interview
process
the bbc did all the right things the
person behind the report says
in my view the recruitment process for
the religious affairs correspondent
was targeted at finding the right person
for the role
although there were some shortcomings in
the process by which he was re-employed
i am satisfied that he was ultimately
appointed because his knowledge
and experience were considered to be the
best match to the requirements for the
role
at the time he goes on to say i have
found no evidence that martin beshear
was rehired
to contain or cover up the events
surrounding the 1995 panorama program
in my view that theory is entirely
unfounded
it also goes on to say that those who
were involved in the recruitment process
actually were not aware of the fact that
martin beshear had used these fake
documents and lied
uh surrounding the panorama interview
there's also
uh in the press release we've had from
the bbc a statement from the bbc
director general tim davey in which he
thanks ken macquarie for carrying out
this report
and says it finds the recruitment
process was targeted to find the right
person for the role
and it was conducted in good faith but
it does go on to say that while the
report find processes were largely
followed at the time it is clear we need
to reflect on the findings to ensure
consistent
best practice is applied in our
recruitment and also i think this is a
really interesting line it says finally
it is without doubt that had the
organization been aware
of what is now publicly known because of
the dyson report
martin beshear would never have been
reappointed
so in many ways this is a good report
for the bbc
saying that actually when it came to
re-employing martin beshear they went
through all of the right processes but
once again
reaffirming that if those involved in
the recruitment process had known that
he previously lied
and acted in the way that he had the
deceitful way that he had to secure the
panorama interview
he simply would not have been
re-employed in that role